i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation
tonight a matter of life and death
i wanted to put pillar over her face to
try and enter suffering
but then it occurred to me that no
father should have to be put through a
situation like this all the time that
i've opposed it i felt a bit of a
hypocrite
because i thought that if ever
heaven forbid i was
for example
to contract motor neuron disease
i would want it for me had the law
permitted his life to be ended ahead of
time there is no doubt in my mind
that one or more of us would have sold
out for death
neither i nor colleagues
have the objectivity to make judgments
because our compassion prevents it many
people have said to me if my life was
like yours i would kill myself my lord i
have a huge amount of privilege in my
life
but if people think this it becomes very
easy for them to conflate disability and
a six month diagnosis and decide that we
have no right to live
last week a petition calling on
parliament to debate the legalization of
assisted dying broke through the 100 000
signature mark that compels mps to
consider the so-called right to die once
again
advocates say that no care pathway
however sophisticated will completely
mitigate the pain and fear of terminal
illness
and that no one should be denied the
choice to die in a planned and dignified
fashion
opponents argue that no law can
guarantee a good death but that opening
the door to legal assisted dying
devalues the lives of many who can live
a good life and place intolerable moral
pressure on health professionals
our choice if we need to be helped to
die
should those who assist us be treated as
dispensing mercy
or as criminals
in the next 30 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight the conservative pier
and former cabinet minister lord michael
forsythe and the crossbench peer and
paralympian baroness tani gray thompson
michael what is the precise legal change
that you are seeking and
why does it matter to you
well i would like people to be able to
be assisted to die where they are
facing a terminal illness and where
perhaps they're in great pain
and i think they should have that choice
why it matters to me is because i would
want it for myself but the law doesn't
provide for it
it is available to some people who can
go to
switzerland if you've got ten thousand
pounds but they have to go without any
family members because of the risk of
criminal uh conviction
and it seems to me uh that uh if you
want something for yourself but you're
prepared to deny it from other people
you need to have a hard thing
and when my father was dying i went to
see him and he had a day or two to live
and he was in great pain
and i said to him look i'm really sorry
that you're in such pain and he said
well you're to blame michael and i was
completely taken back by this and he
said i said well how do you mean i'm to
blame and he said well you have
consistently voted against the right
to die
and i
i wanted that and i can't have that and
um
that changed my whole
approach but of course the reasons that
i voted against before are still valid
which is you need to have protections in
place which we don't have at the moment
uh tani uh why do you oppose this so
strongly
so i think the legislation as it
currently exists uh allows the crown
prosecution service and the police to
look at things on a case-by-case basis
and the reason i oppose it is because
actually when you look at the
legislation you know it's six months
prognosis it's two doctors uh settled
wish that sounds
good
um and if you'd asked me 25 years ago
i'd have been you know arguing for a
change but for me when i started looking
at this and i knew when i came to the
lords that this is one of the things
that would be debated you start looking
at the how the why
the when who the drugs that will be used
and you know unfortunately on our side
there are no quick sound bites to
counteract the argument of changing the
law
but uh the detail of what can happen um
really concerns me and then also as a
disabled person
um you know uh you look at
the do not attempt resuscitation orders
that were put on disabled people at
start the pandemic with no consultation
and the cronovirus legislation
i i really worry how disabled people
would be treated if this became law okay
well we start with actually one piece of
common ground which is that both of you
seem prepared to change your mind when
confronted
with a particular piece of reality so
let's see where that gets us and let's
look start by looking more closely at
your case michael before we do i want to
hear from dr amy profit she's the
president of the association for
palliative medicine and she opposes a
change in the law and she's talking here
about her experience with a patient with
cancer affecting her bones
i saw her
the very day that the house of lords was
debating a sister dying recently and she
begged me to end her life because of her
fear from the stories in the press of
dying people
with uncontrolled pain and suffering
she couldn't bear the thought that this
would be her future too
i said the law prevented me from doing
that
within a week of specialist care
expert symptom control and interventions
she had stopped talking about death
and was planning instead
to attend a really important family
celebration
had the law been different
that time and effort would have been
spent assessing her eligibility
arranging
for her to end her life
uh michael how'd you
deal with that because essentially
your case is about choice
but uh
in a sense what tami prophet is saying
is that in that case
the the choice might have been
um a false one for the patient well of
course it's a very reasonable argument
to put but we don't we we don't need a
crystal wall we can actually see the
future by i mean there are 200 million
people in this world who live in
countries where there is
um assisted dying and we can see whether
or not that results in
disabled people as tany suggests feeling
pressure and there's no evidence for
that whatsoever
um and
uh if someone is going to make a choice
of that kind then they are going to have
to
um be assessed and they're going to have
to talk to doctors and
in the end are we really going to deny
individuals uh the choice because um
some people may make the wrong decision
they can make the wrong decision now
by going to switzerland and there are no
safeguards whatsoever so we we need to
have some kind of regulated framework
and we can see how that operates in
other countries and where taney and i
think could agree
is it's ridiculous that the house of
commons has not been able to debate this
properly and consider proper legislation
because what happens with private
members legislation is the opponent's
table lots of amendments and it runs out
of time
we may we may get to this point where i
think we probably will agree it's good
to talk about this but
tony what do you how do you respond to
michael's
main point that actually
uh that uh people should be given this
kind of choice and
choice is quite an arbitrary word
because some people have more choice
than others and it's very privileged
position to be in so
you know we look at some of the
jurisdictions around the world uh and in
america
uh where
you know people um
are being encouraged to to make this
so-called choice so in oregon if you
don't have great medical insurance
you're offered assisted dying instead of
cancer treatment
if you look at canada where the maid
legislation has expanded really rapidly
there are a number of disabled people
who've said you know very openly that
they feel that they're being or will be
pushed down this road so you know every
jurisdiction
expansion sorry tanya to interrupt you
but the expansion in canada has resulted
uh because of judicial activism in the
courts which you were arguing was a
better way of of dealing with these
matters earlier on
in what way sorry in the the exactly
canada's expanded quite rapidly sort of
eight times the number of people in
canada and and you can argue once the
the law comes in people know about it
and become aware of it then more people
will opt for it but not because of
legislative changes because of actions
in the courts but but it's expanded
however is expanding but you're arguing
we should rely on the judgment of the
courts and and i'm not i'm not arguing
that at all i'm just talking about
expansion and actually how disabled
people no but earlier
let's just stick with this and whatever
whatever the reason whether it's
judicial activism or your point is that
the experiences that more people have
been drawn into
as it were the net of uh making the
choice to end their lives so in vermont
you now no longer have to see a doctor
the doctors doesn't have to know you so
in terms of expansion they can now do it
by skype or online anorexia
mental health so you know one of the
reasons you know right to die
organization in the uk is already saying
you know if the law passes there
shouldn't be that six month prognosis so
it's not just the law as it currently
stands which you could argue this is the
potential legislation we're looking at
but the fear of expansion
the the point here is you can pass a law
but you don't know how it's going to
operate in practice and we may start to
encompass people that you didn't
anticipate
it's interesting that tani has focused
on
the expansion of the rematch
that is the reason why we need to have
legislation which defines very clearly
to whom it applies and the circumstances
in which they can make that choice at
the moment we have no protections
whatsoever i mean uh one of the things
that people worry about is pressure
perhaps from unscrupulous relatives to
encourage people um at the moment
people can go off to switzerland and
there is no protection whatsoever and
that is why it is much better for us to
have parliament debate this matter
something which the scottish
parliament are way ahead of westminster
on so we could end up with a situation
where we have one law and one part of
the united kingdom and a completely
unacceptable situation in the rest of
the united kingdom but if the law
changes
could you see the potential for say
another harold shipman being covered up
because
i i want to pursue some of those and i
want to talk about the what the
neighbors are doing um we talk a little
bit about your uh position michael let's
let's
let's look at uh yours now tany um but
before we do that let's hear from david
mintz he has a form of incurable cancer
cancer called acute myeloma he also
watched his daughter die from cancer and
he supports a change in the law
i'm not saying that i would actually end
my own life even with a sister dying
it's just that that option should be
available to me should my pain and my
suffering
get to the point
where it becomes intolerable a change in
the law
it's a compassionate change it's
something that that that
the terminally ill
need it's not going to happen for me but
i would like to think that it's going to
happen for other people
and i want to highlight my case
to make
mps aware
that there is a lot of suffering
going on with the terminally ill
tanya you were making the point about
the impact on disabled
people
but there are others who are
not disabled before they know that
they're going to die sooner than they'd
want to
why would you deny them the ch this
choice that michael's putting forward
because i'm i'm not convinced by the
safeguards uh and in terms of uh
doctor's ability to make uh a judgment
on that settled wish so the mental
capacity act of 2005 you know hasn't
been fully implemented you know doctors
are saying that there are challenges
with making that assessment so
it's how much time and this is where you
get into the detail very quickly how
much time do you spend deciding whether
someone has a settled wish and in canada
uh you know
232 people changed their mind after our
skin for assisted dying then changed
their mind 22 of those right up and you
know at the point where they were meant
to take these lethal drugs so the
settled wish thing is not something
in in some cases that is permanent you
you see the cases and they are
heartbreaking they are absolutely
heartbreaking and i've watched family
members die in
not grow up you know really not ways
that you would want them to or ways that
you know you you kind of hope but
that's probably
made me even more determined that that
actually the safeguards and the ability
to make some of these judgments aren't
that not you know it's gonna be really
difficult to to actually have this in a
safe way to be to be clear what we're
talking about when we're talking about a
sister dying
is uh medical practitioners uh
being given the power to
uh
prescribe
um lethal drugs which individual will
take themselves we're not talking about
anybody else being involved in the final
in this final act
so
michael how do you respond to what
turnage just said
well i respond by saying
there's a lot of suffering as we've just
heard
but also people make the choice
and we have large numbers of people
who
are facing a terminal illness committing
suicide i mean there are cases i mean
one man who lay down on a railway line
in front of a train to be decapitated
people shooting themselves with shotguns
uh horrible things and to argue that
um we must deny people the choice in the
face of that and you know tiny at the
end of the day we're in the house of
lords we're not elected but we do live
in a democracy and consistently polls
show that more than 80 percent of the
population want parliament to change the
law to give people the kind of choice um
that the
many people wish they may not exercise
that choice of course
and we have a fantastic hospice movement
in this country which provides
palliative care but there are limits to
palliative care and there are some forms
of illness which you just cannot
take away the pain or you know motor
neurone disease where bit by bit you've
until eventually you're unable to
breathe and why should we deny people
that opportunity and then on the other
side you have things like the liverpool
pathway where we allow people to starve
themselves to death a horrible way to
end their lives so why not be more
compassionate
well the question i think that is asked
is you know do you want a good death no
one would vote to have a horrible death
but you know palliative care is still a
postcode lottery in this country so
baroness finley's amendment in the
health bill you know has has moved that
on quite considerably and and that's
really good but if you don't have the
right support you don't have the right
palliative care you're not able to have
that conversation uh it's
it
it's a it's final there is no going back
but it's not either or you can have good
palliative care and still leave people
with a choice i mean i've supported i
mean i've raised hundreds of thousands
of pounds for people involved in
palliative care so in the countries
where assisted suicide exists nuclear
benelux countries actually palliative
care has gone downhill and there's less
palliative care and less support
it's uh the suicide rate hasn't
dropped it's it's gone up in a lot of
cases the devil is always in the detail
of this
is that
uh changing the law just doesn't solve
all the problems and what we we know
from this country is that the way you're
told of a terminal diagnosis is really
important
because if you're told in a bad way
actually at that point people would
request the option of at some points
being able to end their lives
but
that that's such a moment in time and we
actually need to spend more time with
people and getting the right support
around them rather than saying okay this
is it your life's over okay
we've we've looked at both of your cases
in a little bit i won't say massive
detail but a little bit more detail
let's
let's see if we can actually find uh
some common ground or at least a common
understanding now both of you talked a
bit about
safeguard tony can you imagine
a world in which
there were safeguards
that would satisfy you that it was okay
to have this kind of legislation
i really struggle to be honest and that
is not what you want to hear um because
it's how long do you spend assessing
somebody to make sure they have a
settled wish how much to investigate the
family around them you know number of
people who said to me where there's a
will as a relative
um you know
and you
the cost
of doing that and the time it takes
makes it
quite potentially quite burdensome and
that is not to kick the can down the
road but i'm i'm not convinced
uh that there are enough safeguards that
would
would make okay for the people who feel
they're a burden we push down that race
michael give it a go what what what sort
of safeguards do would you imagine
would follow follow a legislation a
piece of legislation
that um
permitted assisted dying i think that
might conceivably satisfy tiny i think
the
support of two doctors which covers the
shipment point which tania made
and also some proper counselling um
and i don't think this would be
something to be
necessarily rushed into um but you know
all i'm arguing is
please let the government provide time
so these issues can be properly debated
and so
the concerns which tani and others are
expressing can be
enshrined in legislation because at the
moment there are no safeguards at the
moment uh people can kill themselves or
they if they're very wealthy they can go
to switzerland a horrible thing without
their without their relatives and family
because they run the risk of prosecution
the courts are crying out for parliament
to act and it's parliament's duty to do
so we can't just leave it to the judges
and we certainly can't leave it to the
prosecutors to decide whether or not um
to bring a criminal charge
in cases where where people have died
sorry
one thing i don't think we talk enough
about is death in this country and you
know i'm
well we've had a lot of it recently yeah
and um you know i i don't come from any
religious point of view i think when you
die you die that's that's it there's
there's nothing else so i think we have
to talk about
uh death in a different way and we've
got to have uh some some better
understanding around it
but if we change a lot we also have to
talk about what drugs would what lethal
drugs would be used and how'd they be
used and what cocktails and
i think people need to know some of
these things we can't do that if we
don't have the legislation and if folk
like you are preventing parliament from
deciding it
i'm not preventing parliament i'm not
stopping any mps debating this or
the government
i think very well i think what michael
is saying that there have been
procedural devices that amendments have
been loaded into the building in the
house of lord that stop that essentially
means that things run out of time we
could get into the procedural question
but i'm i'm still keen to try to see if
there might be a place in which there's
something worth talking about the
government's general view at the moment
is this is a matter for parliamentarians
as individuals parties shouldn't get
involved and so on that's why there
isn't any uh government world behind it
well actually the real reason is no
government minister wants to get into
this because
who needs it but
it clearly is an issue
it is clearly something that people
broadly speaking think they know about
three quarters of the public supported
change
and we're seeing the changes in scotland
potentially
possibly the isle of man
tony what
you say you would resist
or you can't see it but
can you envisage a situation where
essentially the neighbors
scotland and isle of man have permissive
legislation and people are basically
getting on the ferry or going to gretna
green
is that
that's not a great situation is it no
it's not and then those jurisdictions
have to decide whether they want
almost tourist assisted dying so whether
they
if legislation is passed in places like
jersey uh which they're looking at at
the moment whether they want it for a
you know jersey resident or how they
they would get around it so um no that's
that's not ideal anyway i don't think
that's how jersey would like to be
thought of as the place to go
but there's a danger here that we end up
with
the worst of all worlds which is
he saying there's no safeguards here
there's no safeguard for people who go
to another jurisdiction
and we have a sort of to be wild to be
fair to death to be fair to the um
scottish position i think they would
require one year of residency i think
that's that is what proposed so there
would be no option
i i don't know about the situation in
the isle of man um but it's certainly
well they're still considering it yeah i
mean it's it's rather similar to the
situation
of people going to switzerland i mean i
think the most significant thing is
until recently the bma and most of the
royal colleges had been opposed to this
now they're neutral i think there's a
realization
um
that you know change has to come and if
you if you think about the legislation
difficult things which are matters of
conscience like abortion like the
abolition of capital punishment like the
legalization of homosexuality
all of these matters
were private members bills where the
government provided time and support and
parliament was able to consider them
properly and i don't think anyone would
want to reverse that legislation and all
of them suffered from the same problem
which is that private members bills find
it very difficult without government
time so why not have this discussion
amongst elected people and let
parliament decide
so the bma going neutral is an
interesting change a lot of the doctors
who voted in that are no longer
practicing if you ask palliative care
doctors
uh they they don't want this uh and
there is a movement which says okay keep
persisted dying out of health care but
then that comes back to my original
point of who and when and how and
you know people i think assume it's
going to be this hollywood death and
that's how i hope my death is and you
know but but actually
again from all the jurisdictions and and
even you know the canadian association
which is uh the maid assessors so that
you know that's the group that is is
overseeing it
um
are saying that you know it is not
hollywood death there's nausea there's
vomiting you have to take 100 pills it's
horrible stuff to take
and that's that's the right we do need
to have that kind of detailed
conversation it's not an injection it's
not euthanasia you know the reality is
so far from hollywood death for for many
people
i don't know what you mean by a
hollywood death but well you slip away
the soft focus and it's nice and it's
lovely with everybody around you but
there's no hollywood death in those
people who take their own lives because
there's no alternative we're coming to
the last few minutes and i just want to
put to both of you that um
somehow
there needs to be a resolution of this
because i think everybody would agree
that where we are now is not
satisfactory that there needs to be some
way of resolving this question so
you know i think they're involved in 13
attempts at the house of lords to pass
legislation and it keeps coming back and
uh we have these very painful debates
all three of us i think have experienced
um
painful deaths of people close to us
how can we resolve this is there
a way of debating it is it a royal
commission is it simply saying that
somehow
parliament has a time limit
to decide it do we think about
horror of horrors a referendum how would
you how would you how would you resolve
the question teddy
uh
i'm not sure a referendum is is
potentially yeah okay
um because again you know it's do you
want a good death or a bad death that's
quite a binary question uh probably you
know the comments we we're not there to
run the country the house lords we're
only there to say to the government of
the day have another thing so
potentially you know um
you know the government has to give it
time
we're in agreement um i think the
government i i don't think this is
something you can leave to private
members i think the government has to
help a private member to draft a bill i
think many of the points which tony has
made do need careful consideration
and you need to have a debate and the
government has got to make time whether
the government are prepared to do that
two to two years away from a general
election i don't know but what i would
like to see is
the parties who are likely to be in
government
giving a commitment in their manifesto
that they will allow time for these
matters to be properly debated and
considered in the same way as we did
with other matters of conscience in the
past would you agree with that
uh i agree that i don't think any
government's going to do it right now
and uh i'm not sure many mps are very
keen on the idea of it
in which case the debate shouldn't it
won't go through but it's not
satisfactory that we're in this kind of
no man's land situation
we are unfortunately
out of time i think we've actually to my
slight surprise got somewhere i think
you both agree that the current
situation
isn't satisfactory utani would not want
to go where michael wants to go i think
that you michael do recognize that
tony's points about safeguards are
extremely important
what you also agree actually is that the
people who should really be taking the
lead here seem to have gone
missing at the present time and um i
think if anything comes out of this that
you've both thrown out a challenge to uh
our members of parliament um
particularly the house of commons
moments of the house of commons a big
pardon to get on with it
to gird their loins have some courage
and deal with this incredibly difficult
question i appreciate both of you and
the way you've dealt with that
uh thank you to both of my guests uh
that's it from us stay with us we'll
have all of today's news coming up after
the break
[Music]